I just decided to go on a diet I made
that decision immediately I've seen a
picture of myself it was taken it was
taken from the side when I was not
wearing a shirt or sucking in my gut or
aware that pictures were being taken and
that's not realizing my front profile
does not match my side profile turns out
from the front
I'd like a dude who lifts weights from
the side I was like a dude who shouldn't
cuz it's probably bad for the baby I I
blame my fiance it's like I get a lot of
mixed messages regarding nutrition at
home like such lecture me about healthy
eating which will come across a lot more
genuine if she shouldn't also like to
constantly bake me delicious treats
which I guess his different instincts
inside of her like part of her wants me
to be very healthy so I can live a long
time and she doesn't have to die alone
but another part of her wants to fatten
me up just enough so that no other woman
will ever love me
but it is ridiculous she'll make me like
my favorite cookies I'll start to eat
them and then she'll save me and thanks
to me she liked ant dan what are you
doing just just stop it seriously how
many of those are you going to have
today I was going for all of them I
thought these were delicious cookies I
didn't realize you would bake me shame
biscuits and guilt wafers I tease them
but we get along very well we don't
argue very much and usually when we do
it's just like communication stuff which
is every relationship like our main
argument by far she feels like I don't
listen enough to her and I uh I don't
care about that
like I could definitely you know listen
more I could definitely work on more
effective listening and I will when she
works on telling better shorter stories
like why is it always a listeners fault
that makes no sense like people don't
live in story human beings throughout
history every culture have loved to be
captivated by a good tale
if someone consistently doesn't love
your stories well maybe you're no
Stephen King okay let's write less
details more action wrap it up here and
there she's always telling me she's like
are you even listening to me right now
no how could I be you've been talking
for 25 minutes straight about some lady
at work I've never met having boring
problems I don't care about if this was
a channel I would have changed it 25
minutes ago I have a nine-year-old son
Kyler I have a seven-year-old daughter
Munro they're the great kids they're
happy they're healthy they're smart
which is the one thing I would kind of
just you know just crank down a bit like
you smart kids are a lot of work yeah do
you have them yeah yeah
do you have you know I think a lot of
questions they're like activities like
to go outside they are rarely if ever
interested in just quietly laying on the
couch and patiently Washington 8-hour
Criminal Minds marathon and that and
that gets old you know sometimes I get
jealous when I'm at the food court at
the mall or Chucky Cheese and I I see a
couple dumb kids and I think that's a
sweet life right there
Masum sometimes I fantasize about a
couple just easily please glassy-eyed
little mouth-breathers I could just
throw in front of a spongebob marathon
with some string cheese and some juice
boxes and carpe diem the day is mine my
son I he skipped the 2nd grade when he
was 8 years old he was tested and we
found out that he was reading in a 12th
grade level and I was happy for him but
I was a little sad for me I think I
think every good parent wants their kids
to eventually accomplish things they
weren't able to but a this mountain
right
here's what I like about it I don't know
for sure that I read in a 12th grade
level like I assume I do but I've never
been tested and I'm never getting tested
now I'll be emotionally crippled like if
I took the same test that he took when
he was 8 and you got a 12 what if I took
that tomorrow I got like a 5 I probably
panicked take drastic measures paint his
room with as much led as I could get my
hands on now make sure you top aluminum
for the rest of the childhood just
deadlines this fish tastes like mercury
cuz I got in there with a gap that's why
you'll stop getting mercury fish when
you stop knowing but the fish taste like
mercury think about that Professor hey
thanks for watching be sure to click
subscribe to see even more great cone
and clips you may now return to your
pirated movies and creepy Japanese
pornography